- [Kirby] When that water comes
in, it changes everything.
- [Krisha] It just kept dumping
rain for hours and days.
It was heart-wrenching.
- [Priscilla] It rose
overnight very quickly.
- [Nathan] It's pretty mind-boggling,
in more ways than one.
It was a pretty emotional
moment, to say the least.
- [Greg] People are worried
about their families
and their loved ones so I
started thinking about,
how can I help with this?
- [Woman On Radio] The office
of Emergency Management
is calling on owners of
any powered water craft
in Greater Houston to assist in the rescue
of those trapped in flooded areas.
- When we woke up that morning,
we discovered that we are an island.
All the major highways,
all the major roadways were underwater.
The only way we could talk to each other
was mainly through social media,
and so we created a Facebook group
called the Fairfield Relief Effort.
- My brother actually
saw something on Facebook
saying that 'we need all
the help we can get.'
Any flat bottom boat or shallow
water boat that can come assist.
We just kinda looked at each
other and the rest is history.
We got home, loaded up the
boat, and headed up that way.
- There was a line of
people just wanting to give --
to either go do rescues or donate.
Anything to help the others.
It was so overwhelming,
the amount of people
wanting to support us.
We had well over 200+ volunteers,
and we've rescued over 125 people.
- [Nathan] We got in touch with Delmar,
and, you know, we asked, "Is there
anything we can do?
"Do you need help or anything like that?"
We took him back to his house
and he was able to save a few things.
- Austin came up here and
helped me pick everything up.
They are examples to
everybody in this county.
They take helping people to a new level.
- Our son's kindergarten teacher, she
posted online that her
in-laws needed to be rescued,
that their neighborhood
was flooding really fast,
and they needed somebody
to come down and get them.
- Krisha, right away messaged me and then
they rescued my in-laws.
- [Kirby] My particular
vehicle has a snorkle in it,
so it's able to go into waters
a little deeper than normal.
- [Krisha] There were
road closures everywhere,
and their neighborhood
was completely underwater.
- [Kirby] To get from Point A to Point B,
we're navigating around
people in canoes and boats.
- When we finally got the family
back here to dry ground, if you will,
you know, Mrs. Brewin, she says, "Thank you,
how can we repay you?"
I was like, "Listen, you
taught my kid how to read."
It's fine, forget it.
- Houston is such an incredibly large city
with so many people from
various backgrounds,
but it didn't matter.
People came together to help each other.
I was in constant awe of my neighbors,
of my entire community.
I just got chills now.
- When people are in need,
it's just an instinct that kicks in.
I was just one small part of a community.
- Everybody pitched in.
I mean, it was a group effort.
I mean, I’ve grown up in Texas;
I know what people are like here,
and they're pretty awesome.
We're pretty good at
taking care of each other.